Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program once again, Anand Giridharadas, who
is a journalist and commentator.
The new book is The Persuaders at the Frontlines
of the Fight for Hearts, Minds and Democracy.
Really appreciate having you back on.
Speaker 4: Thank you for having me back.
Speaker 1: So intuitively, I have the sense
that on political issues, it is now more difficult
to persuade people even when the facts are
on one side.
And I think maybe the first place to start
is, is that perception accurate?
Is it true that there we are in an era where
political beliefs are in a sense, more like
sticky or stubborn or difficult to change?
Speaker 4: Yeah, well, I think another way
to think about that is, is the is the fraction
of people who are very difficult to persuade,
has that fraction of people grown.
I think that's in a way what we mean when
we talk about polarization.
Right.
That that the country has sorted into these
kind of two political tribes.
But I think part of where the Persuaders book
starts is from the premise that we have confused
polarization for meaning that no one is persuadable
anymore, which is not true.
It is the case that significant minorities
of people on each side are not persuadable.
And what defines that group on each side,
in the left and the right is not how strong
their opinions are, but how deeply held those
strong opinions are.
Which is to say you can imagine someone we
all know, this person who will huff and puff
about a strong border.
Right.
But you could imagine someone who huffs and
puffs about a strong border who has watched.
80 documentaries about immigration policy
and reads books about it and goes to, you
know, militia men meet ups where they talk
about the border.
That is not a persuadable voter.
That is someone who not only has a strong
opinion, but as a strongly held strong opinion.
You know, that person has talking points to
rebut any objection you might make the person
you know.
And that exists on the left.
Also, there's people who, you know, have a
strong stance on universal health care because
they've really they thought it's part of a
worldview.
They thought about it, they bolstered it.
It's part of their community consciousness.
But then there are other people who vote alongside
the strong border guy or the universal health
care person who may have that opinion on the
surface but have much shallower roots of that
opinion.
They haven't watched a bunch of documentaries
about border policy.
They have not read a bunch of books.
They have what I think the corporate world
is sometimes called strong opinions, lightly
held.
Right.
And persuadable voters are people who might
have strong opinions but also have them lightly
held.
They are, as are not.
Shankar Ossorio, one of the many brilliant
persuaders I write about in the book, says
These persuadable voters are people who can
be toggled into a very progressive way of
looking at the world or a very conservative
way of looking at the world.
To give you an example on immigration, when
the thing in the air.
Is imagery of people crossing, migrants crossing
the border in caravans.
Those persuadable people can be toggled into
with the right messages, can be toggled into
a very right wing nationalist.
Fear based.
Close the border.
As you will remember a couple of years ago,
when.
Family separation.
Was the dominant thing we were all seeing
on the news every day.
A lot of those same moderate, persuadable
voters were, if you remember, using the phrase,
this is not who we are.
Right.
Those same people who are in a different circumstance
might have been toggled into a very right
wing understanding of the border.
We're in that moment with that set of facts,
that set of stimuli toggled into a very progressive
understanding of the question.
And so this book is about how you speak to
those significant numbers of people in the
middle who you don't need most of them.
You don't need all of them.
But if you can win many of them in a given
moment, in a given election, on a given question,
it can make the difference between very different
futures.
Speaker 1: When people often will call in
and ask about persuasion, whether it's at
a dinner table or whether it's in a national
election.
Oftentimes the conversation is different,
and we've talked with people who specialize
in kind of changing beliefs at what we might
call the retail level, which is you build
a relationship with someone that you personally
know.
And there's often many conversations and here's
the average number of hours that it can take.
And that's sort of like one bucket.
The other bucket is widely held beliefs for
large numbers of people for the purposes of
winning an election and how views can be shifted
in those sort of situations.
Can you talk a little bit about with that
second group, which is for the purposes of
winning an election with views that might
include Trump was actually the winner in 2020,
it was stolen from him.
Or, you know, Democrats want to do abortions
when a baby is already six months out of the
womb or whatever the case may be.
What are the techniques that can be used in
those sorts of situations?
Speaker 4: Well, the last the the actual examples
you raised are in a way not examples of arguments,
but examples of disinformation.
Right.
So there's a chapter in the book that is about
persuasion in the context of disinformation,
which in some ways is a separate, separate
question from traditional, you know, traditional
political persuasion.
Speaker 1: So.
And just to be clear, it's different.
Why?
Because it's simply based on a misunderstanding
of a fact rather than maybe conflicting morals
or something like that.
Speaker 4: Exactly.
Like if you and I are having an argument about
whether, you know, a fetus is a person deserving
of legal status and protection from homicide
laws or not.
Yeah.
That's not an issue of you and I having different
facts or senses of reality.
Like the facts are broadly agreed.
It's a, you know, whether a fetus is a person
deserving that protection is a moral argument
that depends on, you know, interpretation
and that and a lot of politics, you know,
or just like is a 31% marginal top tax rate
or a 39% one going to enhance economic growth
and broadly shared prosperity?
Again, no one is we're not, you know, in hopefully
in a good version of that conversation, we're
looking at a common set of facts and historical
data.
And when we're interpreted as things are complicated,
right?
Yeah.
The examples you cited really are where we
are now in many cases where it's like moon
is made of green cheese territory and you
know, the world is run by a global pedophile
ring run out of a pizza restaurant on Connecticut
Avenue in Washington, D.C., kind of thing,
yeah.
Q And on 43 million Americans, by the way,
now believe in the underlying fantasies of
QAnon, which means 43 million Americans could
be understood to be in a diffused, dispersed,
you know, virtual cult.
Yeah.
So the issue you raise is very important.
And I spoke to two different experts for that
chapter about what we do about this problem.
How do you persuade in the context of people
having really their own sense of reality that
is non-reality and the truth?
You know, one of them was a cult deprogramming
former cult victim herself who got out of
the cult and then helps other people get out
of cults one at a time.
Right.
And she's now thinking about what do you do
when millions of people are being manipulated
in cult like ways by leaders like Donald Trump
or into disinformation?
And then I spoke to a cognitive scientist
who works a lot on COVID and I mean a climate
and then now COVID disinformation and trying
to figure out how do you deal with that and
what both of them said from their different
vantage points that really surprised me was
that essentially we may need to treat disinformation
as endemic in the age of the Internet, that
there's not going to be a I mean, literally
a disinformation artist owns Twitter right
now.
Yes.
The idea of the idea of shutting off the spigot
feels, I think to both of them, a little fanciful.
And what they suggest is sticking with the
kind of public health endemic analogy.
If this is endemic, if disinformation is going
to be in the air.
The answer is to inoculate people against
it.
Don't worry, this is not like an actual shot.
But a public health approach to disinformation
is what they suggest, which is essentially
an educational an educational shift, where
basically the way, you know, things like sex
ed were once taught to people in their homes,
if at all, or people figured it out behind
the barn or whatever.
Now, you know, sex ed came to be thought of
as something that was crucial to any child's
development.
The state, the society has an obligation to
have everybody have a common minimum understanding
of their own bodies and sexuality and where
babies come from and and so on and so forth.
Well, I think being able to detect and kind
of interdict these common tactics of cult
manipulation and disinformation may become
viewed as a core part of an education.
Today, you know, critical thinking is what
like here's a passage of a book.
You know, what are the three main ideas and
which one you that's not?
Speaker 1: No, no, no.
That's quite lacking.
Speaker 4: That definition of critical thinking
was, you know, not adequate, I think, to,
you know, 15 year olds being up against Rupert
Murdoch.
And we need to fortify them and to detect
how and when they're being conned.
Speaker 1: Because you mentioned cults.
And we've we've also interviewed experts on
cults and getting people out of called former
cult members, etc..
Obviously, the inoculation ahead of time,
preventing people from getting sucked in in
the first place.
Absolutely.
A great thing.
Important thing.
Reality is a lot of people are already sucked
in.
What methods of persuasion have you seen be
most effective at getting someone out of a
cult?
Speaker 4: So the the interesting thing here
that I learned again from both Diane, Ben
Scudder and and John Cook, the scientist,
is that what we are?
What we tend to do instinctually when we encounter
those people is as backwards, almost designed
to not work and drive them further into the
arms of the con.
What we what we often do is make them feel
stupid.
We often try to rebut their points point by
point.
Hagel on reality present data.
A lot of us are, you know, on the other side
and the reality based community are like interested
in data and evidence and we kind of lead with
that.
And we don't understand what's going on there.
And so what both Diane and John educated me
on is basically they view as someone who has
who has succumbed already, as you say, as
someone who there's kind of two warring forces
within them.
That person and one of them has is badly beating
the other.
The first force is the desire to have the
world make facile sense.
We all have that desire.
Every single one of us has that desire.
Yep.
Cults and disinformation prey on that desire.
Right.
The world is complicated.
Globalization is complicated.
Covert is complicated.
Q And on comes in.
It's actually very simple, right?
It's appealing and it hooks certain people.
The second desire that is also in every human
heart is the desire to be no one's fool, the
desire to be no one's dupe, the desire not
to be a mark for the powerful, manipulative
people.
And what has happened in people who've succumb
to disinformation is that force number one
has really outgunned force.
Number two, in them, force number two is kind
of lying latent.
And so the thing that works is not factual
rebuttal or evidence or making them feel dumb,
but helping them see that they may be being
used by powerful people who are manipulating
them for the benefit of those powerful people
and not their benefit, helping them see the
ways in which they've been tricked.
To be clear, this is not going to work all
the time.
It may not work most of the time.
But it has shown some results.
Diane Ben Scott, who wrote about her own experience
being in the Moonies.
And, you know, these these the programmers
came and tried to.
Her mother organized.
They tried to come and get her out.
And they were telling her the beliefs about
Christ are not true.
Here's the truth about this.
Here the truth.
None of it worked.
Well, it worked on her.
She was sitting in this room and they start
telling her about brainwashing techniques
in Mao's Revolutionary China.
Mm hmm.
And what was interesting is she didn't have
emotional defense mechanisms around Mao's
Revolutionary China.
Right?
Right.
It was not coming at her straight.
It was like exotic a world away.
Right.
And so maybe she listened a little more easily
than she might have if it had been straight
out.
Here's why what you're saying about Jesus
is not true.
And she started hearing the list of Mao's
brainwashing techniques.
And she just recognized them.
She just and she started she just kind of
described, I think, the world like crashing
pieces of glass all around her as a sensation.
She felt just and.
And she kept muttering herself like, what
if this was all a lie?
And so, again, I don't want to I don't want
to overstate how easy this is.
Speaker 1: Right.
It doesn't always go that well.
Speaker 4: But but that I think that's the
dynamic you are aiming for, planting a seed
of doubt.
And I would say lastly, this comes up again
and again in the book, not just on this information.
Persuasion often involves trying to displace
what is in people's heads, not trying to replace
what is in other's heads, and certainly not
being perceived as having an agenda of replacing
what is in their head.
Simply trying to displace to make people have
questions again.
Speaker 1: So displace rather than replace.
Makes me want to talk about the group of canvassers
you spoke to in Arizona and how they were
focused on changing people's minds on on immigration.
What were they doing?
Speaker 4: This was a you know, of all the
of all the different people I studied and,
you know, try the different types of persuaders
I wrote about from the scientists to educators
to activist organizers at these canvassers
in Arizona filled me with so much hope they
were engaged in this experiment called Deep
Canvasing that grew out of the stinging defeat
of gay marriage in California in 2008, on
the night that Barack Obama got elected.
Right know an otherwise an otherwise kind
of glorious night in American history that
was, you know, that overshadowed this really
awful defeat by referendum in California.
In other words, most people's neighbors were
against.
The view of gay people as full human beings.
That was a they didn't know that.
They didn't know that.
That was the majority view.
The vote lost L.A. County.
Gay marriage lost L.A. County.
You know what we would think of as a reasonably
decent place to be gay in the United States.
Gay marriage lost L.A. County in 2008.
And so these gay rights activists in the L.A.
LGBT Center and others were just in a funk.
And, you know, one of them described walking
around the grocery store and you're, like
standing in the produce aisle being like.
Like, Does this person next to me want to
exterminate me?
Like, does this person think I'm not a person
like who you know, it's not Mitch McConnell
and like 2000 miles away, it's not people
in the Central Valley.
Like, I am surrounded by people who do not
think I'm a human being.
And it you know, again, this is not for the
faint of heart.
It's not for most people.
But a certain subset of these gay activists
in L.A. in that time were like, I want to
go to knock on people's doors and find out
why they hate me.
Again, you may be listening to this thinking,
who the hell would want to do that?
Yeah.
And, like, totally great to stay at home and
not do that.
Yes, but these people wanted to go do that.
They wanted to know.
They actually had questions.
Right.
They didn't they couldn't understand why people
couldn't understand them.
And so they went.
And what started kind of informally, helter
skelter talking to people listening has since
developed into a method that is remarkable
that I witnessed at it's kind of, you know,
maturity in in Arizona, where these canvassers
go door to door.
They don't do 32nd conversations about have
you found your polling place or do you have
a flier?
They spend 30 to 40 minutes lovingly, patiently,
strategically talking people through their
views, their deepest prejudices, as well as
values that might conflict with their prejudices.
They don't they again, displace, not replace.
They don't come in there and say, well, you
say this about immigrants being lazy, but
do you know, in fact, David, that 25% of immigrants
work 900 hours?
That's what they write.
What they look for is.
So you said immigrants are lazy.
Do you know any immigrants personally?
Oh, well, yes.
I had my gardener.
Manuel is Manuel is Manuel lazy?
I know Manuel works like harder than most
people I know.
And is he the only one whose family is, like,
better?
No, actually, his kids are so hardworking.
They're like in college, but they're also
working two jobs.
And at some point you just say to them, how
is the thing you said at the beginning sitting
with you as you now?
Tell me about Manuel and you just let it be
quite the great little silence there for.
Yeah.
And people.
You know, this may sound either believable
to you if you're listening to this or not
believable.
But not everyone has probably thought about
these issues as much as you and I might have.
And people listening to a podcast about these
issues might have people stand there in the
door and they're like.
It's true.
A lot of the immigrants I know are actually
the opposite of lazy.
Huh.
I wonder why I always go around thinking they're
lazy.
Yeah, right.
That happens.
That's real.
It's true that people will say a thing about
trans people.
And then I saw this powerful video of one
of these canvasses.
A black woman in California.
Talking about her own trans niece and basically,
like ragging on her own trans niece and then
the canvassers like.
Have you ever been discriminated against or
treated badly because of things you couldn't
control?
Interestingly, as a black woman in America,
she did not connect it to being black.
She did not connect to being a woman.
She connected it to being like moving from
another city and working in a job in L.A.
and everyone in her job in L.A. being like,
you should you should go back to where you
came from.
Yeah, that was just like not from being around
there.
And she was like, that sucked.
I just went to work every day and it just
sucked to like, I can't help that I lived
in another city.
Right.
And then he is like, and how did that feel
to be just seen and treated that way?
And and you see this.
You see it like a wave.
Crash on this woman's face like, oh, I am
to my knees.
What those people were to me right now.
And so I think this work of deep canvasing,
like so much of the work of persuasion, depends
on a kind of faith that many people, if not
most, can change, can move.
Think what they think, in part because of
what they've seen, what they have not seen,
where they've been, where they've not been.
And that exposure and conversation and listening
and empathy can get us there.
This is not an argument to go around knocking
on dangerous doors and, you know, hoping to
be respected if you're a marginalized person.
This is a book about some people who choose
to do this work out of their own volition
because they believe that people can change.
Speaker 1: The book is The Persuaders at the
Frontlines of the Fight for Hearts, Minds
and Democracy.
We've been speaking with the book's author.
Anand Giridharadas, always great having you
on.
And really great, great book.
Very much enjoyed it.
And we're going to link to it and encourage
our audience to pick it up.
Speaker 4: Well, thank you so much for having
me.
It's good to be back.